[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
sur tv 60,18 nouvelle édition spéciale
en ce vendredi 17 avril
le coronavirus fait toujours des
victimes dans le département trois cent
dix sept personnes sont décédées dans
les hôpitaux yvelinois d'après les
données de santé publique france publié
hier jeudi soit 11 morts supplémentaires
en 24 heures est mais pour la troisième
fois consécutive le nombre
d'hospitalisations a baissé il s'établit
à 987 sur le territoire et diminution
également du nombre de patients en
réanimation 12 ans - en 24 heures
et puis ce chiffre 949 le nombre de
retour à domicile suite à une
amélioration de l'état de santé dans les
yvelines
32e jours de confinement en france et
des mesures qui sont peu à peu allégé
dans les yvelines par arrêté le préfet a
autorisé est la réouverture de 11 marché
dans plusieurs communes rurales du
département et ce dès ce week-end parmi
ces villages notamment clairefontaine en
yvelines montfort l'amaury aulnay sur
mauldre ou encore poigny la forêt et des
marchés dont l'entrée sera limitée en
termes de clients ou le respect des
gestes barrière sera de mise et ou du
gel hydroalcoolique sera disponible pour
connaître l'ensemble des villages
concernés les arrêtés sont consultables
sur le site de la préfecture des
yvelines
malgré la crise sanitaire du coronavirus
les collectivités continuent le travail
tout en respectant la distanciation
sociale ce vendredi le conseil
départemental des yvelines s'est donc
réunie à distance à l'ordre du jour plus
de 70 des libérations ont fait le point
la dernière séance remonter au 31
janvier dernier salle comble au conseil
départemental pour voter le budget de la
collectivité pour l'année 2020
mais depuis la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus a débuté impossible donc de
tenir une assemblée en format normal
afin de respecter les gestes barrière ce
vendredi matin la séance se faisait donc
à distance c'est l'organisation des
séances dématérialisée du conseil
départemental et de la commission
permanente pendant la durée de la
défense pour faire face à l'épidémie de
cofidis n'est ce pas ce qu'il faut que
le pays commence à tourner mais c'est
surtout ce matin on a pris des décisions
qui sont liées directement à la crise en
particulier clan substantielle apte est
un secteur que tu au plus grand que j'ai
envie de dire devant 7 millions nous
moi j'étais dans une salle à qui est
conçu pour cet exercice était avec cinq
collaborateurs même avec une distance
réglementaire ont porté le masque pas
moi parce que parler dans un micro avec
un masque
c'est un exercice quasi impossible seul
élu présent physiquement conseil
départemental à versailles pierre bédier
34 autres élus assister à la séance en
audio conférence diffusée sur la chaîne
youtube de la collectivité vote est
question se faisait donc à distance nous
allons maintenant passer la parole à
marie hélène aubert pour 18 c'est fait
merci monsieur le président bonjour tout
le monde
la séance a débuté par une minute de
silence en mémoire de patrick devedjian
le président des hauts-de-seine disparu
le 29 mars dernier du coc vide 19,73
délibérations étaient au programme de
l'assemblée qui a duré environ trois
heures à retenir à un plan daide
d'urgence de 27 millions d'euros pour
faire face à la crise sanitaire
la mise en place du pass plus les
collégiens pourront bénéficier d'une
carte est crédité de 80 à 100 euros pour
des activités extrascolaires dédiée au
sport et à la culture dans les yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine
enfin le lancement d'un groupement
d'intérêt public pour la création à
versailles et d'un centre inter
départemental du psycho traumatisme
dédié aux enfants aux retraités
ces traumatismes et donc pour ce faire
nous se lance avec un professeur de
médecine du centre hospitalier de
versailles qui est un spécialiste de ces
questions que pédopsychiatrie on veut se
lancer dans la création d'un groupement
d'intérêt public avec le département des
hauts-de-seine pour mettre en oeuvre des
traitements qui après qu'adapter pour
cette enfance malheureuse et maltraités
prochain rendez vous pour le conseil
départemental le 15 mai prochain avec la
commission permanente qui pourrait se
tenir cette fois-ci physiquement
les entreprises aussi s'adaptent dans ce
contexte particulier certaines ont
réussi à limiter les pertes notamment au
début du confinement c'est le cas de la
pme automation en 2000 qui est implantée
à coignières spécialisée dans la
production de systèmes intégrés dans des
transformateurs électriques
elle a continué sa production le
reportage de nicolas d'andrews l'atelier
a continué de fonctionner malgré le
confinement situe à coignières la pme
automation 2000 fabrique des produits
pour les transformateurs électriques en
respectant les normes sanitaires les
collaborateurs ont continué l'activité
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars baisse du
chiffre 3 mars
tout simplement parce que justement la
durée des commandes qui étaient prévus
pour le wat d'evry l'autre le mans metz
on a géré vraiment je dirai tout car les
commandes de ce qui était prévu
au final est quasiment tous partis aux
menaces ni plus ni moins depuis le début
du mois d'avril les commandes baissent
l'activité ralentit plusieurs employés
sont placés en activité partielle et en
face des chansons qui sont encore là on
est capable de passer à la fabrication
pour répondre à des commandes
ponctuelles ou pour mettre en état du kw
à 4 mètres faire les réglages qui vont
bien ceux des appareils qu'on a des gens
statut disons pour l'instant on n'est
pas en situation critique et oeufs et du
coup on essaie de participer à l'effort
français c'est-à-dire en continuant de
payer nos charges moins importantes
aucune échange le scandale en payant
fournisseurs et ajoie mais aussi tuer
nos clients jouent pour la plupart le
jeu sur le fait des pays aussi leur
échéance au mois d'avril le dirigeant de
cette entreprise estime au moins 50 % de
perte de son activité en 2010 neuf il
avait connu une baisse d'environ 12% en
raison de la conjoncture économique dans
ce secteur et ce soir d'ailleurs ne
manquait pas un numéro spécial du 7 8 et
co consacrée aux conséquences de la
crise du coc vide 19 mobilisation des
grands groupes industriels du
département soutien aux commerçants et
adaptation des entreprises nous avons
aussi fait le point sur la situation
économique dans le département avec le
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines le 7-8 échos
c'est à 21h30 ce soir sur tv 78
ou en replay sur tv soixante dix huit
points comme les initiatives solidaires
se multiplient à saint quentin en
yvelines en cette période de crise
sanitaire une dizaine de bénévoles de
l'association des musulmans de magny les
hameaux
elles livrent depuis le 31 mars dernier
des paniers alimentaires de puériculture
et d'hygiène à des personnes dans le
besoin
une initiative permise grâce au soutien
de plusieurs commerçants mais aussi de
la commune par l'intermédiaire de son
ccas les précisions du président de
l'association interrogé par mélanie poké
pour vous donner une idée on a commencé
à douze familles et là la dernière
collecte qu'on a fait on avait vingt
familles on a passé la barre des 20
les paniers sont sont faits et préparer
nominativement avec la taille de la
famille donc ça permet aussi qu' il n'y
a pas un attroupement et puis et puis
aussi de protéger tous les ayants droit
on les livre donc après il ya des
personnes qui ont les livres directement
devant la porte maintenant on a des
numéros de portable donc c'est beaucoup
plus facile on les appelle et on en
disant voilà il ya votre coup les dons
qui nous font coucou par la fenêtre en
disant c'est bon et on a des personnes
qui sont placés dans un appart hôtel à
manille donc larmes ont fait une des
pauses pour tout le monde mais en
espaçant bien
de son côté l'entreprise cassis et
malice situe à montigny le bretonneux a
décidé de préparer des repas pour le
personnel soignant après avoir stoppé
ses commandes sur les six salariés il ne
reste que les deux gérants pour cuisiner
et livrer des repas dans des ehpad ou
chez quelques particuliers yvelinois
mathilde et demi et mélanie poker pour
le lead à elisa ses préparations de
commandes dans leur entreprise kcc
malice elles ont dû mettre de côté leur
activité de traiteur et ont décidé de
livrer des repas à domicile pour les
particuliers et le personnel soignant
on avait envie de faire quelque chose
pour les soignants qui se mobilisent en
ce moment et du coup on a lancé une
canette sur le site internet qui
permettait à la base de vendre les repas
pour proposer aux personnes qu'ils
souhaitent d'offrir un repas hauteur de
8 euros pour des soignants donc en gros
au off la matière première une matière
première de qualité non cuisine et
ensuite on va livrer
différents établissements aujourd'hui on
va livrer deux ehpad pour les livraisons
les deux gérantes ont dû s'adapter et
appliquer des gestes barrières sur le
chemin elles se rendent dans des
commerces de proximité pour récupérer
quelques dons avant de se diriger vers
les pas de la mgen
nous on est effectivement à l'arrêt mais
il y en a qui se bat tous les jours pour
essayer de ba de soigner au mieux les
personnes touchées par locaux vides ou
les personnes qui sont un peu plus
faibles et du coup on a essayé bas de
rejoindre des circuits qui était déjà
mis en place
on abat de par la distance c'est un peu
compliqué donc on a mis ça en place
au menu ce midi pour l'équipe soignante
linguini truite brocoli et asperges du
fait maison qui ravissent est cadre de
santé
ce qui me touche c'est de voir qu'il ya
beaucoup d'élan de solidarité de la part
de beaucoup de d'entreprise qui
finalement peuvent être en difficulté
financière mais qui malgré tout
continuent à faire des dons 2 et des
dons via des offres de repas un élan de
solidarité que le personnel soignant
espère voir se prolonger
notamment pour le matériel médical comme
les masques élégant qui pourraient venir
à manquer la chaîne de solidarité s'est
agrandie pendant la crise sanitaire
plusieurs chefs notamment se sont joints
à l'élan pour cuisiner en faveur des
personnels hospitaliers avec nous jean
baptiste lavernhe mourad zanni bonsoir
bonsoir bien connu dans les yvelines
chef étoilé de la table du monde à
versailles propriétaires aussi de la
cave et du bistrot du onze alors vous
avez participé à l'opération un bon
repas pour bien soigner elle a été lancé
cette opération par la fondation
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
pour le lundi de pâques vous avez
cuisine et 50 repas au centre
hospitalier de montreuil mais les landes
va pas s'arrêter puisque vous allez de
nouveau cuisiner ce week-end c'est ça
pour d'autres hôpitaux
ouais tout à fait voilà en fait on
essaie de
de faire un rendez vous hebdomadaire
pour pouvoir cuisiner une on essaye de
passer à deux fois par semaine
donc tu vas l'idée c'est de récupérer
des denrées avec tous les commerçants de
versailles qui font vraiment preuve est
suivie d'un super élan et il ya vraiment
un élan de générosité qui est assez
impressionnant dans cette ville là on ne
récupère aujourd'hui toute la
marchandise pour dimanche ça sera
peut-être de l'europe à guyancourt et on
va essayer de donner ce rendez vous là
tous les dimanches
est ce que je vous disais juste avant on
va essayer de rentrer un rendez vous de
plus dans la semaine
pourquoi c'est important pour vous
justement de se joindre à l'élan de
solidarité que l'on voit dans toutes les
professions en ce moment pourquoi aussi
apporter votre pierre à l'édifice
cuisiner pour pour ce personnel
hospitalier va pour deux choses d'une
part d'une part je pense que je pense
que nous on a des mains avant on avait
notre potager notre potager qui ne
servait plus à rien qui fait que les
restaurants étaient fermés et ça a
démarré comme ça à l'envi l'envi de de
servir à quelque chose
il ya des gens qui sont dans le besoin
actuel qui seront dans des difficultés
au quotidien que nous on voit de loin
moi je suis très respectueux de tous ces
métiers là je l'étais déjà mais je suis
encore plus aujourd'hui parce que je
pense qu'on sera encore plus compte de
ce que ça représente et je pense que
c'est la moindre des choses leur donne
un coup de main à moindre échelle mais
voilà si ça peut leur donner un peu de
baume au coeur
moi je voulais surtout pas qu'on parle
de nous c'est vraiment pas l'idée
serment l'idée qu'on parle des soignants
et qu'ils soient du mieux possible au
quotidien voilà si on peut les rassurer
avec un bon repas et l'opération vous
allez me le confirme elle a été rendue
possible aussi parce que cette chaîne de
générosité se sont joints les
commerçants de versailles vous vous
n'êtes pas seuls vous êtes accompagné
des commerçants de versailles ouais tout
à fait pas fait l'initiative vient de
laurence lorenzo qui a qui est président
de l'association la maison de valentin
est celle qui est ce lien et cette
chaîne cette chaîne cette chaîne dans
versailles avec tous les commerçants
donc vous avez gaudin
igo ard la boulangerie vous avez
fromagerie le gall et j'en oublie il y
en a plein et qui donnent chacun ce
qu'ils peuvent ensuite on les livre aux
restaurants et et on les cuisine et puis
on les livre les lieux on les livre le
lendemain alors vous allez nous dire
dans un instant qu est ce que vous avez
prévu de puiser ce week-end mais là pour
le lundi de pâques
quel était le menu pour le personnel de
l'hôpital de montreuil bas pour le lundi
de pâques du coup on a fait on a fait le
fameux agnew de cette heure donc on a
fait j go qui était braisé accompagné
des cartes d'un maraîcher avec qui on
travaille
et ensuite on a c'est un petit crème de
bris avec raison corinthe et aider à
noah hostile entre et en dessert un
petit fondant chocolat avec une
confiture de lait fait frétiller nos
papilles il ya peut-être des yvelinois
qui s'apprête à passer à table qu'est ce
que vous avez prévu pour ce week-end de
cuisine africaine on a réussi à avoir
des poulets donc on va faire un poulet
avec un bon gratin de pommes de terre
avec gratinées au fromage à raclette
ensuite on va car un camembert avec avec
partie raison ça on va chercher à faire
quelque chose d'un peu original et on va
faire un petit chèque en terminer de
quoi nous donner
l'appétit vous le disiez ça reste
poursuivre au delà de ce week-end l'idée
c'est de reproposer ce rendez-vous le
plus régulièrement possible
ouais tout à fait l'idée c'est d'aller
jusqu'au bout de ce confinement est
d'aller au bout de
jusque jusque quand les difficultés
seront terminées dans les hôpitaux
donc voilà temps content qu'on peut le
faire on va le faire avec grand plaisir
et puis j'espère que d'autres chefs
il ya plein d'autres chefs qui le font
parce que ça va continuer et il faut
surtout pas lâcher je pense que laurent
blanc le plus difficile en avoir marre
et voilà pour vraiment renforcer nos
envies de merci et bravo jean baptiste
la vergne mauritanie je rappelle que
vous êtes le chef de la table du 11 à
versailles bravo pour cette belle
initiative qui va servir au personnel
soignant et qui a bien mérité un bon
repas bravo d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui
sont engagés dans cette lutte contre le
coronavirus ces mots bleus et aline
resteront à jamais au panthéon de la
chanson française christophe c'était un
ce jeudi à l'âge de 74 ans est décédé
des suites d'une maladie pulmonaire le
chanteur s'était produit à plusieurs
reprises dans les yvelines à versailles
ou encore à saint germain en laye lors
de l'estival de 2018 elle nous l'avions
rencontré en 2014 quelques semaines
avant son concert à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux
il s'était confié à nicolas gerber moi
j'ai pas du tout formaté dans le style à
une allergie ans de ça voilà c'est deux
mois de studio paf atone album c'est un
truc que j'ai pas fait depuis pas mal de
temps
non moi je suis
je sais pas trop ce que je suis
d'ailleurs je suis vraiment dans le la
brède passion le son c'est commencer une
relation une relation aussi entre
guillemets amoureuse avec des machines
avec toujours cette envie de de créer
demande où le progrès de que cet album
là se ressemblent surtout pas à aimer ce
que nous sommes
donc j'ai couture mais mes albums sauf
pendant je les fais
[Musique]
il en comptera dix rencontres
je puis dire les mots bleus mon compte
et avec les yeux
l'appel récent ajout e
il peut être démodé christophe s'est
éteint ce jeudi à l'âge de 74 ans et
c'est d'ailleurs en musique que l'on se
quitte pour refermer cette édition
spéciale l'air de we are the world de
michael jackson repris par des étudiants
de 22 pays du monde l'initiative nous
vient d'une gargenville oise julie
qu'elle étudiante en arts du spectacle
les paroles ont été traduites en
plusieurs langues et réécrite en lien
avec le thème actuel de la pandémie due
coronavirus merci de votre fidélité
restez chez vous c'est important et très
bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
m
[Musique]
mais
commencer
[Musique]
mais
à